Well, well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
No ma'am.
Like I had it all.
He listen to this show a mom.
Yeah. He likes stamps.com
and he knew our website,
Baba
cause everything,
it's everything that's ever
thought of Alba. So Rachel's Otoc
start the show. It's so
major. Every go. Ah, we
oh nice. Thank you. Became, yes.
So I think men milk Monday's the best
day of the week in the sexiest also
because man, milk is really the
most powerful way to start your day.
It's full of vitamins and proteins
that takes really strong into it.
Sort of very,
very happy.
No.
Well go,
go to your mom's house.
We're talking circle.
Christina pushes it.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
How's that Magma Manda Hey guys,
sneaky became yes.
So I think man,
milk Monday's the best day of the week.
What's wrong with your mouth? Yeah,
what's wrong with her mouth?
What's happening? It's a,
she's doing it on purpose,
right?
It's like a sexy thing to do.
She's over over pronounciating
partner lunch, eating,
eating, eating the word.
Um, I see this a lot on, um,
Instagram stories and on general,
on the Internet.
A lot of girls like to talk even sexier
and they'd like to freeze their face.
Only talk with our mouth. I was
hot. I was watching, I won't,
I won't call out her, but, uh,
she was doing a video and her whole
face was frozen comedian or no.
Yeah. And uh, but it just,
it's just the bottom jaw move.
It was very creepy. Oh, I already
know. I already know. Yeah,
because you're talking about
a guy that looks like her.
Here's a guy that looks like her and I,
and I'm sure there's reasons for it.
Oh,
there's reasons which I do too.
I'm not throwing stones cause I've done,
I've injected things into my face,
but,
but the whole thing,
I just so sexy,
honestly believe that if everybody
started their day with men milk,
we could potentially achieve world peace.
Because after you had it,
you're just so happy and
energetic triggers. What's up?
Dude was boring man. Milk
this. And he's funny because I,
I do think a lot of women think
that if they act this way that out,
like they're going to win a lot
of male approval. But it's, but,
but she really winning your
heart and mind or is it yeah.
Is it working is what I'm saying.
This works.
We houses not working. What part
of you thinks this is not working?
I mean cause she married you based
on her man. North Mondays are my mom.
I'd marry her in a second.
What about your brother?
Would you marry your brother
if he was like this? Yeah,
I want to be non binding at the
top teeth and at the bottom teeth.
Oh did she just bleach the tops?
Look Kinda looks like it in this frame.
I can't just for a dental.
I mean I'm, this isn't it,
this is not an official dental updates.
I'm not Gunna,
that's why I'm saying it's not official.
This is off the record.
You have a cleaning coming up Monday.
Oh you're doing and you're doing the
laser whitening the same day. Okay.
How was this not an official
dental update? I'm sorry. I
mean, how is it not, sorry,
I just got excited and I, my
brain is working slowly today.
I'm, I'm so sorry. Okay.
I'm sorry. Do you want to search for
the, I don't have to search for it.
The Tanger, whatever it's
called Stinger. It's right here.
But I don't know why you
would ignore or agreements.
Dental updates are dental
updates from dental time only.
I know what you're doing is wrong.
I'm sorry,
who was well, because that's really
your dental. I date not mine.
That's why I didn't want to,
I like this.
I'm going on a kind of feeling it today.
On Monday I'm doing a double whammy.
Teeth cleaning and whitening.
And I have cautioned you and I really
wish you would take my word of caution
that that's a lot of painful shit.
And one day, I'm not a woman.
I don't have bad days. That's my favorite
thing that he's ever said. Ooh, awesome.
Yeah. So I'm serious though. I should
whites, you're going to feel it.
You're gonna feel that laser whitening.
You know why I'm doing it though? Yes.
Cause you have yellow, buttery popcorn
team. They're nice. But they're not.
They're not.
I'm not going to make two trips.
I'm doing it for my own because I know
myself. So it's like you have me there.
I'm like, just sign, sign me up for it.
And I made the same exact mistake when I
had my crown put on and then I go, yeah,
well I'm already there.
Why not?
That's why I tapped out of the whitening
early because I was overwhelmed with
pain and why you were
overwhelmed with him though.
You haven't been having your mind to
understand that not everybody is in a
relationship, but get a boyfriend, get
a girlfriend, how fun life is short,
have sex, but of course
be safe. Don't get an STD.
I say protect yourself,
but definitely enjoy life,
man milk. It's so amazing.
It's so amazing.
Many of you have been saying,
but it's not vegan
because it is an animal
product as humans are mammals.
But if you look up,
the definition of Vegan is actually
about not taking advantage of the animals
and not using their products,
stealing away really their
products for your own benefits.
But if you don't a girl and you have a
boyfriend and he gives you his men milk,
you're not taking advantage of anybody.
If anything it is a win win situation.
So technically it's safe guys.
I kind of feel like I would like
to start maybe that position,
maybe start that movement that man milk
is Vegan and it is harmful to the mammal
and that you're taking my
product, my mail. You know what,
I can't help but think of our initial
business proposal of calm gum and didn't
we do on to like the pump station
where you could go and you could have
different races and they would come and
then you could choose your flavor like a
Latin guys just or black guy come gum or
one of your own fantasies come jump was
to have different flavors from
different men in the middle of the gum,
like a tight, like that title wave tools
have this new pump station fantasy that,
I don't know. We came
up with this ages ago.
I remembered the pump station, it's not
called the pump station, it's called.
It was like Jamba juice and it was like
different come smoothies and it was
different guys
come gum is all these different guys
have different races are dumping their
loads can come out of it.
And it's like mentos where you can
buy everybody's race right now or no.
And they're like,
what about these two for new Sitcom?
You'll check them out and then we're
talking about there's something not right,
there's something wrong. Um, yeah.
So I mean she's a really cool
check though. I like her.
I think she's cool. Yeah,
I think the veganism angle is very
important. I really, you know,
I never really thought of the fact that
you were totally taking advantage of me,
but I will say that she is
enlightening me in that regard.
So what are you saying that you want
back payment for all the free loads?
Will I just feel like,
you know,
that you're just using me as an animal
for this product and that that is a,
I mean it's the level of disrespect.
It's a level of manipulation
and I just deserve, um,
credit for and maybe,
maybe I would like you to stop taking
advantage of me, you know, I mean,
that's what I'm saying. What if we used
your product for, other than making,
uh, our son. I mean,
I don't really use your product for
my child using Mondays to feel good,
to feel powerful, feel strong, and nothing
makes you feel as strong as you said,
the best part of your week. I never
said that. You've said that before.
It's really the most powerful way to
start your day is full of proteins.
That makes you really strong. Tug
and loans all the time. I mean,
less so happy.
What is this accent she has?
She says vitamins.
So we know we're,
we're talking Australia, maybe
New Zealand, maybe England.
So maybe, uh, who else has vitamins?
It's like a British thing. Yeah, but she
doesn't have the accident anywhere else.
But she talks, she does talk
weird. It's not American history.
If you can detect something here and by
weird, I mean not American at man milk,
drink it, slurp, it's for Vegan.
Enjoy that man. Milk, drink it,
slurp it, suck it. Likud
did I say lick it already,
but definitely enjoy guys
and have a happy milk man.
Milk Monday.
Hopefully you guys all get a little bit
of milk out of your system and into your
girlfriends or boyfriends and vice
versa. Enjoy each other guys. My,
my theory is that she is European,
but she moved many years ago like Canada
or the u s and so she has a hint of an
accent. Maybe she moved when
she was like nine or 10 yes.
10 minutes. So maybe to the Canadiens
save the two men. No, I don't think so.
No. I say vitamin D. Yeah.
Wait a minute. I'm Canadian.
I should know this. You are Canadian
and Ontario. We didn't take vitamins.
No, no. And Windsor. That's where
I was born. SLURP it. Suck it.
We drink beer for vitamins in Windsor.
It's really the most powerful way to
start your day. That's a stupid dummy.
Cool. What are you talking about?
Dope. What a dope and disrespectful.
You're so jealous. I am. I'm so envious.
I cannot stop thinking and we haven't
been able to stop making fun of the Moose
Soup Lady.
Oh my God.
That was one of the most
amazing women people ever,
ever to appear on the show ever.
Yeah.
Yeah. She's, Oh gee.
People have sent in there a photo
submissions of what they imagined that she
looks like and they're out of control.
I between you, the few of them. Amazing.
Amazing.
Have you seen what they've said?
Um, no. Fuck. Let me see
if I can pull it. No,
but it's really someone wrote
in and they're like, we, um,
in Canada we have these types of people,
they live on the river and they're like,
they claim to be broke, but
they can afford water toys
a lot, which I thought was,
that's like, it's so indicative,
right? Like I'm poor,
but I can afford like
a jet ski and a boat.
Okay. All right. Listen, I see.
That was great. Louie
Anderson from the, uh,
what's the shared goals or something?
Oh, Zach, but golf inaca show.
Yeah, that's Sofa in that
show is I like, and it like,
it's perfect you guys
coming down from this. So
I feel like,
man,
yeah,
I feel like she could probably
charge her the sex crimes. You know,
I can almost hear the the prosecutor.
Yeah.
I'm saying like a defendant,
your honor came over to my victim,
forced herself upon him and did horrific
things that frankly we do not want even
describe here in this courthouse.
Dirty Bitch. You know,
it's like there's,
you can,
you can feel that she is so many bottoms.
So many guys. They were like, I was
real fucked up. I was a, I was damn it.
I was having fucking moose suit back
then with this lady. Just, it was the,
what's her name? We haven't
given her Cheyenne. No rush.
She is kind of a Trish, you
know. Oh, she's at trash. Yeah.
Calm down. Yeah. And Karen
are a trend. Yeah. Seriously.
That's what I picture when I'm
waiting and that lady had it. Yeah.
Oh my God. That's what this is. We
found our treasure. You found tricks.
This totally hurt. That's what she's, Oh
my God, I don't even put that together.
Yeah. And I looked up the recipe for moose
suit. Okay. Cause I'm like, is this real?
Yeah. Yes, that'd be real. It is.
Real people put chunks of Moose.
And now here's the thing. It's actually
very similar to Hungarian Goulash.
Lavish slash
that's what
Goulash lavash Goulash soup.
It's very similar except use moose meat
and there's Paprika in there. Onion,
garlic, Goulash, lie, lie. She's
like I just said Paprika, onion,
some kind of meat in there.
Smokey pepper flavor. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's what I'm
saying. It's, it's just a stew.
But I think they put poverty Kennan.
And that's what I read about Moose Soup.
So it's very similar,
Trish. Trish. God dammit that for sure.
She's so nasty.
She's not a nasty is you and your,
um,
acrobatic farts lately?
Acrobatic farts. Yeah.
I've been noticing and I don't know if
it's because it's a summer dad time.
And you're in your time. I got shorts on
right now. I've got summer shoes on. Yeah.
You're kind of like Velcro straps
on. Yeah. You feel it free.
I over those little shoes we put on
our kids. They're like ugly sandals,
but for kids you let it go, right? Yeah,
it's cute on he ripped them off probably.
I took him outside and then he was like,
ah fuck. He's like, he's a terrible,
come on. I ain't no Quia. So
I'd take them off our boy.
But you've been taking a
lot of license with your,
your acrobatic farts? I don't, I
don't, I mean I'm doing it the regular,
I do my hand gestures. I'll do like
a punch or like a gunshot thing.
Sometimes a leg kick, but don't think
it's any different than, you know,
another time we were even doing
a lot of the diaper me baby,
where you pull your legs up on a cup back,
but not a lot.
A couple more now I feel like it's been
a lot more frequent. Hold the legs up.
I'm like changed me and then I, yeah,
I did that one. I did that sitting up,
which was different because I was up late.
I did it sitting up and it got like
a real interesting pitch on it.
Oh my God.
The best one now.
We were in the living room and the nanny
was over and we were playing with Lj
and then the nanny and LJ go out of
their room and then you rip a horrendous
fart and then you're like,
oh, I gotta take a shit.
And then you leave me there with the fart.
And the whole time I'm thinking, oh no,
the nanny is going to come back in here
and she's going to smell this far and
she's going to blame it on me. And I kept
planning my story where I was going to,
I was just going to tell her like Tom Farr
did, you know she's raised three boys.
She knows what farts smell like.
She knows that those are man farts to you.
And she disgusting. You know, since
we're talking about this figure,
we should bring up this email.
I'm Mommy's after originally hearing
about your podcast or Tom when he was on
Joe Rogan,
I subsequently became addicted to the
listening to all the Shenanigans Youtube
provide for us.
All your segments are hilarious and the
way the sound board gets worked during
the episodes makes my nip hard enough
to cut glass or sorry enough to glass.
I am touching base to provide a small
jingle that I created for your brown talk
segments.
I love the locomotive theme that you use.
I wanted to provide another sound file
you can use in case you want to mix it up.
I took some of the clips you've mentioned
over the past month or so in the
podcast. Compose a small
arrangement to accompany at.
I'm a lifelong musician having
experienced in both instruction and live
performance. I'm a complete novice when
it comes to mixing audio clips on my Mac.
Oh good.
I'm glad we included this solution.
If the file for any reason doesn't
sound quite right, let me know.
I can edit and send it back to
you. Well here we go. This is um,
Levens a submission. He signed off
by saying Tom is a personality champ.
That bird is once again fat, um, Livan
submission of a new brown talk theme.
So you can see what you
think. Okay, here we go.
Time.
It's got a lot of elements. I ain't
no way it's got the Jane, Oh my God.
You there's, Oh, disgusting. I liked it.
I liked it too. That's good. Thank you.
Leave on. Thank you, Lee.
Yvonne, not live on, on leave on. Hmm.
So you name emails. Can we go into
some choice ones that I got? Yeah,
absolutely. Um, let's see.
Hold on. I wanted to see
there's a number of, um,
interesting ones that came in.
Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I want to
find the, we've been asking about, uh,
blind people, um, and
if they can, hold on,
let me make sure. Sorry, I'm sorry.
I thought I had this eerie go.
She's a blind guy on the blind wipes.
So we asked this question a
two or three weeks ago now,
how to blind people know
when they're done wiping.
And we've had a lot of different theories.
Tom's theory was that you go bare handed
and you smell your fingers to see if
the wipe is done. And to which I reply,
why would you use your bare hand? Yeah,
just try the toilet.
Well,
I think blind people are more,
have more in like in touch with
the real senses and they don't.
They like to use.
Okay, so hey mom, did you find out? Yeah,
I'm a blind guy and I believe I have
answers to some of your questions. Yeah.
First off, in response to your
guesses, I can't stress this enough.
You cannot smell the paper.
Paper is unruly.
You're more likely to give yourself
a dirty Sanchez and anything else.
How about that?
Smelling your fingers while safer
than paper still isn't viable.
The paper act as a barrier. Muddying
the results if you will. Second,
as you probably heard, when you lose
one sense, the others get better. Hey,
now a blind person's sense of touch,
much like Burt's current weight
is off the scale when wiping.
I can tell from the friction during the
wiping process if it needs more amazing
between the nerves and the brown eye,
the crack and my fingertips.
The speed and ease at which the
paper moves and years of experience.
You learn what glass and a
clean uncanny valley feels like.
Yeah. Isn't that interesting? He
had vision and then he lost it.
So He's had both, uh,
both sides of the fence,
just unbelievable. Yeah.
That's pretty interesting
stuff, Huh? Yeah, that's crazy.
I also got another Ge.
We are,
she's so good. God dammit, this guy,
he's blind, but he can just, you know,
he's got a great sense of touch.
O m g so also we asked,
uh,
Ken Blind people be
racist. Uh Huh. So, um,
this person writes in, hey, Hitler's,
I was just glass and then the
latest podcast when mommy,
Tina read the email wandering and
blind people can be racist. A subject.
I have some experience and I'm friends
with a girl who has been blind since
birth and me and my friends have made
her guests the races of people in a room
and she always gets it, right. Nope.
I'm not saying she's racist,
but blind people can definitely tell
what race people are just by the way they
speak high and tight. Fucking
Anthony. Yeah, that makes sense.
And the guy's name before that was ray.
Thank you,
ray for sending that email
and about wiping. Very
interesting. Very interesting.
Yeah.
So I'm guessing she's talking about
maybe diction, right? Like you can,
she hears a voice. She's
like, oh, that's a Asian guys.
Can I tell you that when I listen to the
radio, I can often tell black people.
Yeah, we can hear it. There's a
different quality like I, you know,
you can just big words.
No I don't.
I don't think that and I know that
big words now babe.
What? I don't, I don't,
that's not what I'm talking about.
Hi Personality observation and
water champ also. Hi Tom. Okay,
that's,
that's
it's a lot.
Oh also I thought he meant in addition
to all those things but he means,
and then, hi Tom. Yeah, I
like this email already.
Love the episode with our e shave her.
He is a very funny non Jewish Jewish men.
Near the end of the episode when
talking about the houses you've done the
podcast in, I couldn't help but inquire
where these homes were. You know,
on account of me being a complete
creep of poly by non binary.
I happened to notice on the googles map
that silver lake is right next to just
Glassell park. Have you ever lived there
and why don't you live there currently?
Thanks Jean. Rick and Canada. Um,
where did we live?
We live in
Glassell park. That, that totally
near, near near. No. Uh, but no,
we lived in silver lake
and he's right about that.
I mean you want to say what streets we
lived on? I don't know. I'm trying to,
I'm trying to figure out where this
park is cause I forget where it is.
Glass Sell Park is the city,
I think next to it.
It's like a tiny little see
Washington,
that's where hipsters are now to Atwater.
And then silver lake before
our, yeah, Glendale Eagle Rock.
We didn't live in just Glassell
park. Silver Lake. We lived more,
we're over here, right over here
near the reservoir. Yeah. So yeah,
I lived here once on Silver Lake
Boulevard when I was dating you.
And then I lived, we lived over here.
Yeah. Yeah. That was fun. That was fun.
I enjoyed silver lake.
And the reason,
I mean there's a few reasons we don't
currently live there. I think it
very, you know, for us, we just
kind of got lame. We got it.
We had a kid and we wanted to
have more sprawl to a look.
I have a lot of cool
hipster friends is too many.
There's too many of that neighborhood.
It's just too much.
I remember being in my late thirties
and going to the trader's Joe there and
just seeing too many guys with ironic
hats and mustaches and I was like,
I'm done. I was never that guy. I
could live around them for awhile.
I can't run them. Yeah, they they.
It's really kind of for some
racist against hipsters.
Are you hipster phobic or does
fucking, that's how I am. Disrespect.
Respect their pronouns. I should have
been a little more respectful of it,
but I just went for it. You know? I
just went for it. Hey. Hi. How are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Someone wanted to tell you this deserves,
he deserves Christina counterfactual.
Champion repeatedly claims in accordance
with her mother's ancient gypsy wisdom.
I'll turn it in fact, guys farts.
Push the shit out. They do.
This is fake news. Tom Has never once
challenges obviously false statement.
Shame on both of you.
Think about it. Dummies.
You Shit then far to bunch.
No,
you fart a bunch then. Shit. As far
it's pushed the shit out. Listen.
Therefore,
obviously the shits pushed the farts out.
Scientifically speaking.
This is super fucking obvious.
The poop makes gas and the gas
escapes pushed along by the poop.
I mean come on love forever.
Double Pipe slot wife.
Yeah, so what you're saying is
farts. Don't push the shit out.
Just it's a total mind blower.
Wrong.
If we're going out for the horse ever.
We've got it.
We got it all wrong.
God dammit is right.
Shit cannot believe this.
Crazy.
Here we go. Hope we'll just change.
Do you want to say it to your mother?
If she were here, do you want to tell
her mom? This whole time we had it wrong.
You had a wrong mom.
It's not the far to push shit out.
This shit out.
But you know what we can do now that
we are armed with this knowledge. Yeah,
we can teach our son the right way.
Yeah,
we can break the chain in
the family knowledge tree.
Tell our son the right thing. Train
him, if you will. Oh, by the way,
I'm so excited that our son has started
making fart noises with his mouth.
That's awesome. And he's really
started to take to the fart humor.
The fart bought books that I bought him.
It's all coming together. I'm sorry,
I just what? This is a super
brown episode. There's an
male here.
My horrible first to shower.
I just imagined him going so bad here.
Hear it. Maybe I can coach this person.
Hey Mommy's. I originally had my
first shit to shower experience,
but things didn't go so well.
I was having a day where even the softest
of sevens were being put out to Shane.
I'm talking straight up
pissing out of my ass.
So after I made Brown
and wipe to no avail,
I hopped in the shower to clean up
some more. In the middle of all this,
I realized I had to shit again.
Obviously I'm soaking wet,
can't get back on the toilet. So I
decided to go straight down the shower.
No, no, no, no.
The worst part is I had to bend
over and clean my fucking feet.
I couldn't help but feeling low
and loose for the rest of the day.
I was so ashamed of what I had done.
Any advice for this first time
shower shitter? What are your,
what is your experience with
shower Brown's? Thanks Stu. Stu
and listen to this man. There's so many
things you did wrong. Okay. Number one,
you never shut down your shower drain.
I feel like that's just a given and I
should have been more explicit when I
talked about my methods.
Never ever shit in the shower.
That's not the point of shit to shower.
The point of shit to shower is to just
clean up after you're done browning.
So well you need to do is be patient
with yourself, with your browns.
If you know you're having waves, a
painful sevens, give yourself some time.
Why are you hurrying to the shower?
You know it's going to be a longer time.
So take your time with your brown.
Yeah.
And then when you know you're
absolutely finished, then you go shower.
And if not just dry off and get back on
the toilet. I've done that before too.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Why not just wrap a towel around yourself
and sit down on the toilet and then go
back into the shower after
that? It's fine for it. Yeah.
So that's really good advice. I
think. I hope he, he listens to you.
Um, I got a, Oh my God. You know,
I got a breakdown to see if I want
to see if you can break down with uh,
the juice man is talking about
here. Okay. The hill. The juice man.
Who's the deuce man?
Y'All are female.
Unloaded.
That shit will be 1000.
Where you going to be able to bounce
your head and we'll go to the school at
glue. Thousands more that they're
going to pay to pull up and drop.
Drop them off of old fat Buddha Shit.
All from the same way to the side.
Okay.
Do you know
pulling up mother mother fucker trap
in the club
email. Oh, good news,
man. You cannot deny it.
I don't give a fuck. What am I
doing? Entertainment before the sober
entertainment is for
the sober God. Amazing.
Such a great, Yay. I turn a
performer. He's not an a performer.
Yeah,
I mean he is a, what is trap music mean?
I get, what is the trap pussy again?
It's just a
genre within hip hop basically.
But what does it mean
that it's trap music is,
is it's a certain style
of hip hop. Oh, okay.
Well more photo museum amusement
entertainment before the sober
and I [inaudible] is for the sober,
I thought is it for the show bro?
Oh, okay. Is he way saying
right there? I don't know. Shit.
You're the manager bags for the show Bro.
Well,
entertainment before the sober
for the Soba.
Hmm.
Yo this shit.
1000.
Where are you going to be
able to tell all the feet?
Males to females. Okay, here we go. Yeah.
Yeah. All female and Lou, they checked
me in America. This shit will be 1000
Michelle will be one thousand one
thousand what? Like, you know,
more than a hundred. 1,000 it's
going to be like on 0.0 Kazan. Yup.
And we're ready to bounce Jay.
You can do it with balance your head.
Okay.
Stay to the Strip club.
Yep.
Oh,
it was a mall there.
Be able to pull up [inaudible]
the same way to the side.
You pull up in your drop top
with that fat booty girl. Wow.
Yeah. Wow. Keep wires.
This accent from southern,
actually this is, he's Turkish.
No. Yeah. How he's not, no.
I don't know where he's from.
No, but what does that draw is,
is that a southern in the
clue? Uh, I'm not sure.
I'm not sure where he's
a clue where he's from.
Let's look it up and just look it
up. I'm going to guess so. Yeah,
I think you're right, right? Yeah, you're
right. Got that southern draw. Atlanta.
Atlanta. Yeah. That's
funny. I like his tattoos.
So you think you're a cooling fan or no,
I'd have to hear it.
That's the thing I don't
really know. Might really play.
Yeah, I know. Um, you know,
they're all, you know, they're
all in the trap selling drugs.
Um, okay. Um,
that big China was,
she was she traveling,
you know, a, they
give credit to a three, six
mafia for doing it. He's credit,
they're credited with some of
that. Um, trap. Okay. I like them.
You like Gucci Mane? Yep. You
like Jeezy you took a picture
of him once. Yeah, I do.
I like it with them, but other than
that, coming back from Atlanta. Yeah.
See he's on the same flight. I mean that
is trap fucking Mecca, right? Yeah. Yeah.
I could see you. I could see you
starting like a your own group
man. Trap music. Trap Pussy music.
Yeah. Mom, trap pussy. Yeah. Mama,
Mama, Mama Z. It's all torn up.
What did you call your special that,
that's a really good idea. Do you think
my manager would like that? I Dunno.
Could you see his face? I'm like,
I'm going to call it mom pussy.
Like you get your offer and the like,
they want to do it and you're like, great.
It's called mom pussy.
Ah, I don't think so. Um,
you know what's funny?
The other day you were um,
you were talking like an old black guy.
I forget what you'd sell it to.
Are you talking about? I
think you were like, don't,
don't look at the TV because I
remember there was, I had no,
I had a, I had an old boss, um,
well he's like 20 years ago
I used to work for it, Nate,
and he would always be like,
kid got all the kids over here
looking at the TV all day.
And I've heard that before.
Like older black guys, they
always say, look at the TV.
Yeah.
It's such like a specific phrasing.
Yeah. Right. Uh, also it's um, where you
staying, right. Where are you staying?
Staying as opposed like a,
I'm staying over at staying in this
neighborhood. I'm staying at this.
Oh, okay. Not like I'm living there. Oh
wait. Right, correct. Yeah, that's right.
The specific difference in mind. That's
funny. That's interesting to stay,
I stay over on the east side. Correct. As
opposed to I live on, right, right. Yeah,
that's,
that's a very specific thing.
But I always loved the
idea of looking at TV,
look at the quit looking at a TV,
get over here and trying to look at the
TV and I'm trying to look at the TV,
which actually be, think
about it. It makes sense. You
are looking at the TV. Yeah,
that's, that's I think grammatically
and logic are staying on the east side.
Correct? Correct. It's
coherent. Yeah. I Dunno.
I always made me laugh looking at
the TV. Look at the TV man. Yeah.
My old boss used to say that. It's like
we were wasting time looking at the TV.
This is so fucking cool
about to show you.
Okay.
You think you're ready and
I know that you're not,
but okay.
The thing is this guy has given us
so much and he never stops giving us.
Oh,
best part
here is
the, yeah. G. Oh good.
Talking to people on the up in space.
They're literally,
oh, swap, slap,
slap up and they're on like a
station or something. Okay. Okay.
He'll let the conversation begin.
He's going to Dad Boehner out.
Oh goodness. The CSUN. Are
you ready for the event?
Right? Ready for the
event. These two sky nerds,
they're books.
Please call station for a voice
nodes station. This is Garth Brooks.
How do you hear me look at that.
That is so, there we go. Can you hear us?
Yes, I can't hear you.
You sound and look great.
Look at that smile.
Is that the,
is that a real genuine dad?
Look,
you think this is the look of a
psychopathic serial killer. It is both.
And I think this might be
the first authentic moment
I've ever seen from Garth.
Like he's truly in awe.
He's truly, I look,
this guy has so much money and
fame and popularity in everything.
Nothing dazzles him anymore. The fact
that he's looking at humans in space,
I think it genuinely is blowing his dad
mind right now. Yeah, that could be true.
Yeah, be true. Cause she can't do too
many interviews out nurse. When you're,
you know,
hanging on a wall,
do you guys get used to that position or
is there any time where the gravity is
at your feet at all? Is there a room in
there or do you have to wait to get back?
I'll go look it up. Oh, you missed
it. Sorry. I'll just fucking phone.
Tripoli's outside guys.
Kim,
that position or the weight,
is there any time where the
gravity is at your feet at all?
Is there a room in there or do
you have to wait to get back
such a dad?
Man,
he looks like he's dad jazz and
right now it's like man milk Monday.
And I do think they're trimming
his beard a little too short.
They're doing it wrong.
They're not doing like,
he needs to see Alan because this is
not okay. Got It. Good luck. All right,
let's go get the Great Sam. Sorry Sam.
He standing out. Sign as hot as balls.
Good rescue. But wait, let's, let's keep
exploring this because I don't want to,
this is really funny. I think it's really
genuine. Can I stop now? Yeah. Okay.
I'm just excited. I like, but
stop talking. Alright, we,
we ran out and we, uh, we brought
in something we found on the street,
the Great Sam Aaa.
He's got six trashcan.
That's balling.
I'm like six trash trashcan
of all different colors, man.
You guys don't fuck around.
Did I wish we actually had six trash cans?
We have two trash cans. Oh,
to recycling cans. Yeah.
And to um, what is it
green? It's like green,
like poor people don't recycle and
they don't give a fuck about Greenberg.
That's fine. Baller status right
there. I've never been like green,
very green and recycling.
I wash plastic and paper towel. I
mean fucking plates man. No, it's a,
first of all, thank you for
coming. It's, it's, I don't know.
Did we ever have you on before?
Yeah,
I did the other room and we
played a sound body sound.
Now it's something a black guy or
Tom or back. Yeah, we played Tom or
black. Wow. And I did really well. Did
you that, yeah, it's on my Wikipedia.
We've had,
we've had two people almost win it all.
I didn't remember if you were, because
we had two people get one wrong, uh,
one or two wrong. That
was, um, what's her name?
Miss Pat and Rogan the
first time he was on.
And then one guy go,
oh for 10 and as a black
Guy Sydney Castillo,
he got zero out of 10 it
means something too. Right.
That should be just as amazing.
That's true. You're right.
Fuck up that bad. Yeah.
And to be black, not to
know your name. Amen.
I can remember when they tried to
use it in the Oj Simpson trial,
like it was a black voice and
they're like, that's kind of racist.
So it's got a black voice. It's
not, we were just talking about,
oh we're just talking about, I can
tell like when I listen to radio shows,
if the color is black, I know 100%
or my favorite thing is, is uh,
Jason Tebow always talks about this.
They should just do a podcast of Mexican
callers in the sports radio shows
because they're so bad.
And the radio guys have to kind of like
pat do patty cakes with them cause they
don't want to piss off their
entire audience for us.
Everything they should bring
back. Colby Bryant. I was like,
we're talking about the Dodgers here. I
don't know man. I think in, they're like,
hey guy, just talking him through. It
starts with a d there's a black guy or no,
I'm going to say black guy
or a guy wanting to be black.
That's true. Uh, the gentleman, we were
just listening to you, but the trap.
Oh, to see if he can guess. Yeah. Can
you just do the audio or you oh sure. No,
I can do the audio. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Hold on. Let me close this.
I got to close it so that he so
good. Yeah. So let's see. Can you
damn,
that
shit will be 1000 but ain't gonna be
able to bounce sheet and we'd go to the
screw glue. Cool. Oh, it was a mall there.
You back to pull up or an edge rock
talk more off of old fat Buddha Shit for
same way to the side.
Can you guess the race? Definitely
black. And I'm going to go,
he's going to the club and
he's throwing thousand dollars.
Then everybody and his friend
comes up in some bullshit car.
Oh, it's not bad. It's an
interesting interpretation. Correct?
No, no, but that was, I mean, you hit,
you hit some of the important notes.
I think that's really all that matters.
I don't think that guy was looking for
you to ever see that video where the
amigos were almost kind of fight it. The
A bt or course. So good. First of all,
uh, a black award shows are the best
that she just lied, stirring backstage,
stabbings and shootings.
So it's like the two Basser obviously
the Avs and any black horse show,
whether it's someone's either going
to get shot or, oh dean. So you know,
something good's gonna happen there,
but they had them on the
morning show and these,
the literally the black people couldn't
understand what the black people were
saying. They see, hey,
what you're doing so good.
It was really amazing. And uh, yeah,
this, you know, funny Ali Wong last night,
she told me that she went to that and
I assume, well, I assume that like,
you know, she's a known
person that, that she,
she got tickets to it.
Like she's like,
I just want it to be there at the
bet awards. I thought she was like,
you know she's a performer. She went
as like a celebrity. She was like, Nah,
like I requested tickets and I got them
and I went to it like just for fun just
to be at that. That's great. Like that's
what it sounds like. You want it to die.
Totally. Look at these classes. Of
course. I want to go to anything hip hop.
This is how languages start. I mean at
one point there were a couple of people,
everyone's talking the same and then just
things get weirder and weirder and now
that you've got Chinese Spanish and all
that shit because everybody just starts
talking their own fucking way.
I don't know if Christina extra saw the
Migos Joe Button thing. Did you see?
I don't know what you
guys are talking about.
It's like a running joke.
You'll be left off that and boots,
boots,
boots
because ever since when you
went to jail even though.
All right,
we got to wrap this up though.
Hey listen man, I wish I could
talk to him. He goes longer.
Man is one of my favorite groups. I've
been coming for so long. Glad to succeed.
Don't they look like the black agent
smiths from the like Black Matrix?
I mean I thought it was SWV. That's
what I thought. It looked like
we're those bad seventies
polyester shirts to Fred.
Like people could make
everything look good.
They have a license to make
everything cool. It's amazing.
Anything cool and she's pregnant
like still afraid of getting, yeah,
she's going to try it again.
God, they never pull out.
There was a, I'd be afraid. Did you
see, I'm trying to pull this up.
I can't get pregnant twice.
Wait, what? Oh No, no. I'm saying
I just got that a terrible mom now
the blacks do y nerdy. No,
the video edit where they,
they put up,
pulled all the moments from that
and pushed in on it. Like the,
there's an an a cut of everything at that
Migos thing and it was just like this,
the key, they zoomed in on everyone's
reactions. It's like it's masterful,
masterfully done and they were able to
like isolate everybody's own reactions to
what was going on. It was just amazing.
Men See if I can find it. All right,
keep going. Keep going. You're
talking. I just love it dude. I just,
I just love black people.
Yeah.
I'm going to get corn rows
and I know you've had issues.
You've talked about white people.
Cornrows. I've talking about white people.
The corn rows. Yeah. I think I might
do. How much longer can I do corner?
I think this is the end of any corn rows
phase. I have. This is the last decade.
You can do it.
This is like last couple of years.
He can't go deep into your
forties with corn rows to do.
That's the question.
My big to the Mexican hairstyle
says just grow the tops, the tops.
How long? What does that mean?
Uh, like I have my hair right now.
Just let this thing growing. Yeah,
you can do that. Just go longer.
And that corn row it up and look
like Trey from grand theft auto.
That is such a specific look that would
really change your whole audience. Why?
It would make it even weird.
Like I used to have normal glasses when
I went up and I thought it looked like
Mark Marin and then I'm like, my act
is, and mark and Mark Marin's, Texas,
phenomenal, but we're just two totally
different dudes. These glasses,
Tom and I have discussed your glasses
like just laying in bed at night. Last,
Sam Tripoli's glasses are perfect,
perfect.
Talks about how perfect this look
is for people get weird by them.
They get really angry. First of
all, they all think they're fake
prescription.
Oh No,
they are though 100% I ended a
podcast because I went to a guy,
hey, are those, are those real glass? He
goes, no, I go, that's fucking stupid.
And we just had a huge blowup and we
never did a podcast. What do you mean?
I had a podcast called the
international bad boys.
Our me and my buddy were on it and
one day come in and I'm just like,
are those real glasses? He goes, no,
I go, that's fucking stupid. Why?
He wearing fake classes and we just,
it just kerosene on fire. Boom,
exploded and we just ended it.
What was his, um, his, I mean,
his thing was I just liked the way they
look or what I mean, nothing against him.
I didn't mean anything by it. Oh
yeah. And it just got really bad.
Who Was it? Easy Guy Works at the
store. He, we're way cool now,
but I'm happy it happened because now
I'm not in this new podcast called tin
foil hat and I just do conspiracy theories
about lizard people and deep state
shit and creep. You end up 100%. Really?
I love it dude.
But do you really like,
do you really believe in
all the big ones then?
You're like 100% 100%.
Look at building six.
No one talks about building six.
It's imploded from the incident.
You believe though,
that the US government conspired to make
this happen to fuel a war like it was
at one of those? I believe that the, uh,
I think that there are,
we'll call them the deep state creates
problems in order to beg us to save us
from those problems to drug war.
Yeah. I mean, we find out that, uh,
you know that the CIA and one of
their assets was Pablo Escobar,
how all the cocaine get here. You
know, where it went into Arkansas,
who's governor? Bill Clinton went at the
time was smuggling all this cocaine and,
and that fueled the cocaine,
the crack wars, the crack,
a epidemic of all that stuff.
So then they beg us to say them,
the drug war against drugs,
blah, blah, blah. I think it's,
it's totally their moon landing.
I don't know about that one either.
We went to the moon.
We have two options.
Either we've never been passed the van
Allen Belt and it's all bullshit and it's
black ops to make the take money into
putting other stuff or we're on every
planet.
I don't think there's any inbetween.
I think Ron Moore planets I
think were everywhere. Yeah.
Why would we not say talk about it though?
Because I don't think,
I think in my opinion,
if you start saying that there are
aliens and there's stuff going out there,
I think one religion goes out the
door. Yeah. The thought of that.
We're the center of the universe and
that everything revolves around it.
Now there's like Japanese lizard
people running around, right?
Like straight up Asian looking mother
fuckers that that goes out the fucking
door.
I think it causes hysteria.
I think you're right because there's
so many hyper religious people in this
country they couldn't handle and
they control them through religion.
But here's my, my one reason that I don't
buy into a lot of conspiracy theories.
Have you ever done a military gig?
Like where they flown you from
country like the Middle East? Yes.
Have you ever been on the flights where
they schedule you like you're going to
go from Kyrgyzstan to Kandahar if
you've been on those military skills?
Are they ever a organized or,
I'm just saying that the military is
so fucking disorganized and you're
considered a VIP when you do those.
I just don't think that the government
has that much structure to be able to
pull off these things.
I just not that organized.
I understand that and I
totally agree with that.
But I think at the highest level, you
always hear this a lot like a, you know,
I've had discussion with Comedians,
they're like,
somebody would say something at some
point you're like, well people have,
and they kind of get discredited,
but the higher up you go,
there's less people involved. So
the numbers like a, this one comic,
I can't say her name did this, like
she did, uh, the super special forces.
Like we're the best of the
special forces all come into one.
And like every room she went to,
she had to sign a new doc saying that
she wouldn't tell anybody about it and
basically, uh, they'd kill
her if she said anything.
Like that's how top just told you on your
fucking Patt Air podcast to told me a
dog park.
But I,
but the point is it gets
deep and like we're in a,
we have special forces like 130 countries.
It's like I can name 130 countries, but I
always feel like one of the, I mean the,
the level of like for instance,
people that believe
that the moon landing is fake.
You would for it to be fake,
the level of the amount of people
that would be keeping a secret,
it would just, it would
be enormous. I mean,
you'd have to be fooling either
you're fooling everybody who's,
that's their work. Theirs,
they know that. No, it's, it's,
it's kind of difficult to believe or that
everybody involved for 50 years never
told a secret.
I understand that too. I'm just,
my whole p pain is, is the, the,
the farther up on the chain you get,
the harder and harder it gets there.
And they do a lot of,
a lot of analog analyzing you,
your habits, they spy on you, they get,
they get blackmail stuff and the
higher up you go, the more you're in,
the more you're in,
the more you have at stake.
So it's not like everybody at the bombs,
let's say like you're at the
comedy store. Yeah. Like there's a,
there's the open Mike. Hers.
Yeah, there's the regulars,
there's the headliners.
And then there's like the super duper
like theater dudes who are all doing all
that stuff. That's a very
concentrated group of people. Right.
And not everybody down here can go up
to here and hang out there. It's like,
it's very, it's hears of it. Yes.
And like the good and within a structured
environment to get up to that level is
harder and harder.
Yeah.
Now you post really great things on
Instagram. I love your Instagram.
What is it at, at Sam Triple Aaa,
and you have a great Facebook feed.
And I was at you who posted
the other day that the elite,
powerful men of the world are
all pedophiles. Oh yeah, no,
it's true. And here's old gay man.
Yeah, yeah. And here's the thing,
and now it's a right too.
[inaudible] was,
listen,
pizza gate was used to discredit
the pedo gate. So everyone's like,
oh, they're fucking kids and pizza
parlors. No, it's, it's much different.
And it goes,
this is deep state shit.
Hold on. Before we go ahead, go
ahead. Go ahead. The thing is,
I would not have believed that had I
not heard a woman on Paul Gilmartin's
mental illness happy hour podcast who was
a child victim of this exact pedophile
ring. And they would torture
her, keep her in a box,
put roaches on her and rape her and she
would tell she tells a story on Paul and
I'm serious and she's an actual person.
I don't think she made it up.
It sounds horrible. Whoa. That weird
weird shit does exist within the,
this is I, is this more darker than
I feel like I come into podcasts,
change everything he was saying,
well that was just terrible.
It
gets ugly and there's a reason for that
and it's like the higher up you go. Okay.
There's a couple of,
there's a big controversy going on right
now and read it and that there are a
couple of youtube channels and
Daniel Tosh did a big story on it.
The have over like 10 billion views that
are basically like corporate child porn
now. They're not like kids doing like, uh,
but it's insinuation, you
know, and it's like, looks
like, so if you free something,
it looks really creepy and there's
10 billion views on these legs,
right? So what they do is, my opinion is,
is this is how they start the
gather people like they're,
they're analyzing who are watching these
head, these videos, right? And okay,
that's great. And you're
like, okay, we know this guy.
But it's also other people with
darker things going, okay, who's,
who's maybe susceptible to this type
of stuff that's secretly what they are
into. Maybe this guy's
running for politics, right?
So now they fast track these guys and
they put them in these weird awkward
situations, film them, and then
they blackmail the fuck out of him.
There was a famous producer, they used
to throw cocaine and hookers shows,
I mean parties and he would
film everything. So if you
are up for negotiation,
they'd be, he'd be like, no dude, I'm not
going to sign for that. That's bullshit.
It's like, okay, let's watch this thing.
You doing coke out some trainee hookers
asshole. And then you're like, okay,
I'll sign for that. It's
like, I mean, as the money,
you got to think there's trillions
of dollars. Are we suggest,
I mean is the idea that people
in power are all pedophiles? No,
just no, but there's a lot.
There's a lot. Okay, dude, listen,
I feel like I'm, okay. So in my opinion,
within the conspiracy theory community,
there's a lot of antisemitism and I like
go in there and my girlfriend's Jewish
and I go in there and I go, I
go at it. Organized religions.
There's always this like, oh,
Jewish guys run the bank. It's like,
it's all bullshit.
It's all like organized religions are
to these very high up people are just
Halloween masks. They wear
them to move around us. And B,
because the truth of the matter is it's,
and this goes sound crazy as fuck.
It's Luciferian Shit. It's like
very, it's not like, Oh, hail Satan.
It's like very dark art shit.
Now in the Vatican there is
a throne called the thrown
of Lucifer in the Vatican
in which the pope sits and behind him
is this big demon. Do just go, oh.
And it's like,
why is that in the fucking
Vatican world is weird.
It's really dark,
weird shit exists because
there's so many whack jobs.
I do feel like the older I get,
I you realize just how crazy everyone is.
And especially with the Internet,
you can see how crazy people
are all the time. Wait, are you,
please tell me, are you a believer
that sandy hook is a hoax?
I think there's interesting stuff to it.
There's us. What are you talking
about? If there's really,
I'm not saying it did or didn't happen.
Wait how I'm saying there's interesting
things that don't make a lot of sense
involved with it. Like what? Like first
of all, okay. Do you remember Columbine?
Okay. What do we see in Columbine? People
knocking out windows like Ha, like shut,
trying to crawl out to get away.
We see kids running all over the,
we see none of that.
We see one picture of one woman leading
a couple of kids out and it's a still
picture. There's nothing
out. The, uh, the,
the mom who's supposedly died lake
later on, she doesn't really exist.
She's, uh, she wasn't a teacher there,
then it turns out she was
like a substitute teacher
at another school somewhere
else. So there's just all these little
things that we start going, oh man,
that's kind of weird that,
I mean like if you go deep diving into
it and you got to go really deep because
if you're expecting that the,
the, the six of, excuse me,
all the alphabet networks to tell you
everything. Well, back in the 90s,
the cleanse deregulate the media and
we went from a 88 different companies
owning 90% of the media to six
companies owning all the media.
So it's very,
and those companies,
they make more money off of other
shit than they do off of the media.
So the media is just used to fund
their other stuff. So anyways, there's,
there's a lot crazy.
Yeah.
Well what about the fake moon
landing? Garth Brooks, we saw him.
He, he's fake then. Well that's the thing.
Okay, so if the moon landing isn't real,
are they faking? Like all these
conversations with astronauts and shit.
Like when we see them, you can't do too
many interviews out nurse. When you're,
you know, hanging on a wall,
there are thoughts about it
guys get used to that position or is there
any time where the gravity is at your
feet at all? Is there a room in there
or do you have to wait to get back?
Yeah, we uh, we have to
wait until we get back. Man,
I'm missing Nascar man. That's
why barbecue up here, you know,
saying he kind Kinda Husky for uh,
an astronaut. No, he's stocky there.
What's happening?
So thank you from the bottom of my heart
for being such an inspiration to so
many and uh,
making those words count.
Wow. Thank you. Wow. See crying. Yup.
Thanks for hearing the music that says
that's a cool part of it and thanks for
letting me get to be a part of it.
So what's going on there? Do you
buy those tears? He's crying.
Just so those of you not watching Garth
Brooks, that brought him to tears. Yeah.
One of the two years that I guy was
like, I love you. I like your music
drawing that
has,
have you ever had someone compliment
you after a show and then you're like,
what's the greatest compliment?
It's really dirty and you
don't want to hear it.
Come on,
come on.
Wilfy you already ruined my opinion with
your Ms Pearcey so just tell me that
they said it this, it's
nasty. Somebody was just like,
I want to fucking eat.
You know this more.
The most gorgeous chicks I ever seen
in my life goes up and she goes,
your comedy, he makes me feel the same
way I get when I eat my own pussy.
I was like, Damn. And I was like,
that's pretty nice. That's very nice.
And that is a couple of kids in
wheelchairs that were very thankful to,
I did a special Olympic shell and
they were cool. Did Really? Yeah, I
did that. If that's a true, I'd
talk about it on stage and wait.
I remember years ago
I saw you have a will.
Do you do your wheelchair bit for them?
I always get asked to do it. It's a,
it's a young man's joke. I
can't do it. If I go down,
I can't come back. That's like, you know,
it's like you have your
memories of seeing stuff.
I remember Sam seeing Sam do
that in the main room, uh,
like a while ago, long time
ago. I remember you on the,
I actually remembered the same on the
same night. You know, you just have like,
you remember bits and pieces of things.
I remember seeing Aaron cater
the same night on the show.
We all got picked up the same time at
the world famous comedy store by Mitzi
Shore. She had picked us up
because she wanted an uh,
an Arab show and Dunkin was the,
this is so true.
Dunkin Dunkins like Tripoli. Are you a
Middle East? And I'm like, I'm Armenian.
He's like close enough.
And he taught me like there used to be
the secret to how to get picked up by
Mitzi and it was, you do a one
joke about you're a family member,
one joke about your ethnic group
and then do your favorite bit.
And so I had this bit that Joey
Diaz loved. Then I was like, okay,
I'm going to do that. Been at w I did
a joke about my mom power walking.
Then how me being furry,
going to the mall on going to the beach
and I just bit about Asians on ecstasy
that you used to do about how their
visuals are so much better because there's
so much smarter,
right?
Like dumb people's vigils or like eight
bit and their visuals are like Dolby,
Imax, digital sound. And
I get off stage and uh,
I saw Paul Mooney talking to
her and I'm like, aw man, he's,
cause back in the day when you
showcased the comedy store,
people would hijack your showcases
because, because they, they,
they weren't getting spots, so they had
to talk to Mitzi. So she remembered them.
Right. So, um, I looked down at Paul
Mooneys off and I'm like, fuck man.
And I'd had a weird running with
Moonee like two weeks earlier and,
which I was on stage at
this show it at the Hustler,
a hustler adult bookstore.
They had a comedy show there and it was
run by this guy named Johnny Montana,
who's like coked out of his skull and
he would just do jokes about his head
shots for like every week. And I was
due to joke about how, uh, how, uh,
how hard it is to be a white guy.
And I got off stage and Paul
Mooney ran up Migos, oh,
you ate white use Armenian user.
And he dropped the hard and
bomb Ami. Yeah. Wait, Whoa,
we're not the word the m word.
Which one? He, okay. He goes, oh me,
you ain't white. Use a meaning.
Use a Nigga. And I was like, Damn.
The dude who coined the phrase basically
called me the ward. So I was like,
I don't know. Is this guy like me
or not? So I go, I go do the set,
I do the set. And I see him
talking to her and I'm like, fuck.
Mooney's talking to her. Well, it turns
out he really liked me and he goes, oh,
Mitzi, you got picked. This guy is
really fun, which is totally cool.
And I'm always thankful to Paul Mooney
for that. So I come out and I go,
and the whole thing is
after your showcase,
you walk up to Mitzi and you
kind of kiss the ring, right?
So I walk up and I'm like,
Hey Mitzi, thank you so much
for the showcase. She goes,
are you Syrian? And I didn't know what
the fuck's hearing was. And I'm like,
Yep, I'm totally fucking Syrian wa I love
Vienna, Syria and I love Syrian food.
She's like, okay, I want you
in the showcase tomorrow night.
So Jay Davidson had a huge show called
Dublin's and I don't know if you guys
were out here during that board.
Dublin's was huge. He said,
go watch that show.
And I remember giving
Jay Davis a VHS tape,
such a crazy time. I tried to do
a doc on that move on that show.
And of course it got completely
fucked up by crazy people. But um,
so he's doing a show the next night
in the main room, I did a showcase.
This is how cool Mazda Brown he is.
He gets me in. He's a great guy. Cool.
Stewed you offer me one of the guys is
stayed real no matter what's happened to
them. One of the most real dude
you for me. So Ahmed, Ahmed,
Aaron cater myself are all showcasing
eh Mazda's already irregular.
So we go up when we do our set
and we all have really good sets.
Mas wants to give Brett Ernston
so Mazda disappears. Mazda's like,
oh they give it like we can't find Mazda.
Like can we put somebody else up?
They put him up, they put Bret Ernst
stop. Bret Ernst does a showcase.
All four of us get picked up that
day. So on the same day, same day,
what year was that? That
was 99 or 2000 wow. Yeah.
2000 seriously.
100% fuck man,
it was a year before nine
11 because she wants,
she thought that like Arabs are gonna need
a voice. Like that's how crazy it was.
Wow.
Because you picked this up,
but she made us be regulars and worked
a door like I had to work to door.
And then,
you know,
four months after I moved
to La in 2002 I met Sam.
We did the Groundlings together
and he was so fast and like,
I used to be a real knucklehead and you
can leave it like a gun recognizes a gun.
You know what I'm saying? Like you're
like, okay, this guy's fucking good.
So you get to be like, either we're
going to be rivals or we can be friends.
Right. And I'm like, this guy's
so fast. Let's be friends.
So I did to you what was done to me in
that I joined an Improv troupe thinking
it was a standup comedy show.
I didn't know what it was.
And my friend Victor Isaac, who
lives out in la now, it's like,
you're really funny. Come do standup.
I'm like, you know, and I go,
do you do stand up? And you're like, no.
I'm like, you fucking should do stand up.
You're really funny. So I took you around
for like a week. I could, it was, it was,
you're responsible for encouraging
young. Of course, of course.
It's awesome Sammy.
Like what was the other,
what was like the Sushi restaurant
kind of across from Dublin?
They had a show there,
a search without, um,
shit. And I was just talking about
the other day with a Doug Stan hope.
What was it? Miyagi's yeah, and
I was, uh, I basically was like,
I don't know what to do. And he
goes, you just do spots. And I like,
I didn't even understand how that, what
that meant. And I tagged along with Sammy,
went to Miyagi's, we went to the comedy
store, we went in one other place.
And so I just
got to see like, oh, so like, and
then he's like, you know, like,
I'll just do this here.
I'll try it here. And like,
I'll watch them do like 15 minutes sets
and he's like, just do it. Just do it.
Just do it.
But then you did a couple
shows at that place above, um,
the Improv school on libray. You
had a show there, right? Room five?
I did. I did a bunch of like
those little, you know, like,
and then we're off.
Uh,
I remember doing like I was, I
started to know too, I got a,
I started doing the
Improv's gave me mc working.
Oh for you move quickly.
He did Europe,
man, you were at Thompson Guerra.
I always tell people this,
I ran a tiny room in Los
Filez called Tangier.
We were all open makers when Tommy
started stand up when he was 23 years old.
He was good. He immediately like,
you are one of those assholes.
Oh I hate it was like,
are you kidding me? Yeah.
He started and he was better
than all of us and I was like,
you gotta be shitting me.
I had two closing out my open
miker show essentially every week.
Cause you were fun.
You were the funniest one.
Okay. So, um, you were fast food.
You and nick were fast and nick, by
the way, Wagoner, we were also, yeah,
it's also in Sam and my improv class.
He's the one that introduced me
cause he was also had done stand up.
He introduced me to a booker as a comic.
So he goes,
you should put, he goes, you should
a Tom's grade should have them.
And The lady goes, Oh, you're
a comic. And I just went, yeah.
And then she goes, uh, all right. I'm
sure April 22nd you want to do that show?
And I was like,
yeah.
And that's how I did my first
spot I ride and just was always,
that's how I lied to get in the copy.
So then there was cat, what's her name?
Kat Wrightman.
Right man.
And then there was the trucker from a
smokey and the bandit smoking hot daughter
who's dating somebody from Lincoln Park.
Yeah,
Lincoln Park that she was dating the
drummer from Lincoln Park. That's right.
So hot. Horrible at Improv horror.
Right. But she didn't care know.
And everybody was like, you date the
guy from the apart. And she loved it.
She was like, yeah, I do. I'm so
into it. Then you just took off, man.
I remember you're doing all these little
spots and then you were just gone.
So you were just doing spot and then
you were just touring off of you, been,
you and Sebastian both were row
dogging right out the gate. Yeah. Yeah.
Sebastian was. So, it's a
funny thing about Sebastian.
Sebastian was Sebastian from the drop
persona was there. I saw him
yeah. 10, eight plus years ago.
Yeah. Doing an o our spot. I was just
at the club one. I did the belly rooms.
I used to do a bunch of belly room
shows that weren't like official shows,
you know, and popping. And that dude was
exactly the same. Exactly the same guy.
He honed at anyone out with guys
for awhile. He did for dice.
He opened for dice.
Never would have ever expected that dice
lumped him cause he was like Italian
dice is Kinda got the Italian
thing going on and uh,
just went off and he was just
so,
um,
this shit like Sebastian's new stuff
feels like polished material is just a way
of delivering and like,
and,
and like laying out with a bit is that
feels like a finished product on the
first take. You know, it was like the
first time he says like, I was at the gym,
he's talking about what happened
at the gym today. It feels like,
I feel this is a bit,
it's like what happened today?
He knows like that Doug Stanhope in terms
of that. And he would never say this,
but a like he's been doing it so long,
he knows his voice.
He can anything happen.
Goes Ray through the voice box and comes
out and he's got a point of view. Yeah.
Burrs that, burrs like that. Yeah.
I'm sure you guys are like that. Yeah.
I mean it's like if you've done it long
enough, you know your take, you know,
it's so inappropriate time.
When I were sitting around talking about
our favorite comics and I was like,
my favorite comics are
50 year old white guys.
Like I just fucking love the Shemel's,
the Louis C K obviously
like bill burr in that lane.
All these white guys I've watched coming
up and you're like, that's, to me,
that's still the gold standard layer.
Older white guys guys wrong with that.
Oh,
I just love them while their masters.
Yeah.
I think comedy's going through something
right now where it's like the actual
humor is like the last thing
they care about in a weird way.
I feel like there's so many people getting
pushed forward just because we need
an APP. We need a biracial bisexual
person and you're like, you know,
I'm thinking about sucking black dicks
in front of everybody just to get fucking
something.
Go and you know,
just go on stage and just crushed Jamar
neighbors dick in front of everybody.
Just so somebody will fucking sign me the
something. It just like so true. Right?
There's a sissy.
That guy's Tripoli's suck.
That guy's not great for
the new Gilmore girls.
Why don't you sign on to that?
You got to pick your pronoun or
wrote me them like your pronoun a Pronoun.
You can be a Zimmer [inaudible]
you can be a man, a woman, a man.
I don't know. What is your
pronoun? I'm Zim. Why?
Because I don't want you to
assume that I'm a male. Okay.
You're being really presumptuous and
you're, you're determining my gender.
Let me determine what my gender I respect.
There you go.
I respect your non gender.
Gender. Thank you amgen.
So I don't want you to say what's he
like? Okay, well when you say what Zim,
like are they your they,
yeah. What's Your Pronoun?
That's interesting. Hey, by the way,
I wanted to ask you this because
you do your conspiracy theory,
conspiracy theory podcast,
which is called foil tin foil
hat with Sam Triplet.
Do you ever address,
there's this ridiculous conspiracy theory
about like Armenian genocide you ever
hit than that?
Like they claim that like that,
like the Turks wiped upon. There's a
couple things about that. Is that like,
do you address that when we go
through that they told you like, oh,
they put on this whole charade? Yeah,
it was really, it was really great.
They didn't boo hoo, they got a couple
of tattoos, just made some shit up.
So when did that supposedly like
when's the salary that they happened?
Five or something like that? Ain't no, no,
no. It was way back. I went when though,
what year? 2000. On the, excuse me, 1917.
Oh Wow. And how many, uh,
purported to a million
to a million people.
1 million people? Yeah,
but like come on a million.
But do you really think that many
people died? Why? Because, because,
because people told me because the
fucking let let her networks, ABC, CBS,
Oh, I had, I had, I had an uncle
that was involved in all that.
What did you do at kill by my mother's
uncle. Excuse me? Your mom's uncle.
What was a in a camp? Uh, he was
uh, he had a fucking tattoo on him.
Did the Turks do,
they came in and kicked our dates.
They did last suck our dicks in a
lot of this. So like Dick's talk,
what was the willow suck on
the what? What led to this? Like what
was the event that led to this? I mean,
what's so interesting about Armenians?
Man is I do ask about the law yet.
They do smell good. We
shower in Cologne, I do it.
I have the longest running show ever at
the comedy store is a 15 year charity
event. Happens once a year called
the Armenian bone marrow registry.
And a cousin of mine had a bone
marrow cancer and she couldn't,
they couldn't find a match.
She Still Willis, she is
still, she beat it naturally.
But her mom, my cousin, my
mother's cousin, Yep. Ah,
couldn't find a match her.
And this doctor named Dr Frida Jordan
decided to start in an Armenian bone
marrow registry where people would get
tested and see if they're a Merrill
matched.
And it's like this event that's insane
because you actually see the results of
your, your actions. Like sometimes
you do charity event, you're like,
I hope somebody got that money. You
know what I'm saying? But this one,
like they built a giant hospital
in Armenia and all that stuff.
And the reason we have a unique
genetic makeup is that, uh,
we're basically inbreds oh yeah.
Cause we're the only Christian
country surrounded by most on all
of those tell people. So it's like a, so
we only hooked up with our own, you know,
so it was like our hookup app was
like ancestry.com we genetically,
you guys are a disaster.
Yes. Yeah. Basically,
and that's why we have to have
this whole thing going on. So,
but the Turks who when they were like,
suck our Dicks,
did they not this most of this?
Yeah. They like suck my Dick.
Fuck you guys. Is that, is that guns are,
is that limp dicks just bouncing around
telling two people the second you go
back Mcavoy job, I just
like, it's like a Turkey,
Armenia,
let's go at it.
And then they just had a weird thing
and there were war crimes committed.
And it's so interesting that there's
actually something called the young Turks,
which is,
and I love their political views,
but you're literally named after like
that region's Nazis, you know, they like,
they went and slider a bunch
of people and you're like,
so this was like during world
war one or this was 1917 that be,
so that was, I think, yeah, right around
that or a little before it. Right.
I thought that'd be during that,
is that wrong or right before
1945 was the items were war
in 1914 to 1918 there then,
okay. So let's see. Armenian. You
sound kind of upset about that.
She seemed to be holding a grudge on
that one movie that didn't do well.
Yeah. And you also had a great, you had
Christian, but yeah, we have one movie,
Armenian genocide.
Are you stoked about,
does that eve even Steven?
Well, yeah. I mean,
they're like the most
famous people ever worse.
Kim Kardashians or her two younger sisters
who just last life think a Pepsi can
cues, you know, like hand people,
Pepsi, everyone's thoughts fighting.
That was amazing. So now they put it on
a tee shirt. You see this unbelievable.
The fucking Badass.
These girls through their own images
up over like the doors, pink Floyd,
big Biggie's Stupak.
And how amazing the backlash
was so swift that there was,
I mean 20 like they were testing
like maybe we can get away with this.
Everyone was like, fuck no, you can't
do like, sorry. Anyway, and moved on.
Like it was just, it's a blink of an eye.
They're like, we tried. People said no,
but I don't know that they lost any
of anyone that liked him. You know,
because the younger the tweeny
boppers who's baggy or who's whatever,
they're ripping on basically what Djs do.
Literally Djs do that,
like puffy combs. That's all
he did was he put like, yeah.
At the club over like over like
everybody doing real singing a police,
which is all they did.
You were going to take you and I'm
gonna put you right here and now it's my
finger. Right. I had never thought
of it like that. Right. They're like,
well it looks familiar. Thick.
Yeah. Well I actually, it actually
like when uh, Biggie's mom came out
and was like soap opera, so about it,
they could have been like, did you guys
contact Stang you put out. That's true.
It's so true man. Cause that the hip hop
dead, especially puffy who I, by the way,
I love him. I loved that.
He, I think he's a genius.
That guy is like a mogul and
brilliant in so many ways.
But his era specifically was like,
that's a hot,
so I'm just going to go to it. And
take that, take that, take that,
and then people were like,
that's an awesome song.
And when did you come up with that?
If people were like,
that's fucking in the stones.
Yeah. They may not get a,
did he not get penalized when
they bought it? They license it.
They end up paying a fortune to do
it. Yeah. That's the thing is it?
I guess it is ultimately worth
it. You make enough money. Yeah.
Vanilla ice baby ice ice
baby is just under pressure,
but he got screwed on that.
He was trying to say there's that
great interview where he's like,
that's [inaudible] Donna.
Donna.
No, that's not going to hold up, dude.
The take from like anything involving
Freddie Mercury is, I like blasphemy.
I mean the song is amazing. Have you
ever seen Queen at Wembley Stadium? No.
It is not just a music.
The greatest performance
I've ever seen in my life.
Like this guy owns this crowd.
Like I've never seen anybody own a
crowd before. He's running around.
He's got those bad British teeth
where they're just like the,
it looks like a gateway to a
haunted fucking house. Right?
It's just like the gays.
Yeah. Wait, we didn't finish our, oh yeah,
we're still in the
international space by the way.
It says that Armenian genocide
is a hoax. So, uh, moving along,
um, I noticed, uh, we've been
watching you guys for a while.
I notice a, the gentleman from
Russia pop back there and uh,
what's it like up there where there's
nothing other than what you have in common
is why you're together.
That's gotta be a great feeling.
And I bet you guys probably just forget
that you're from different places.
Oh Gee. There's one. Okay.
At the highest levels of like business,
these CEOs,
they love to go to like dominate tricks
and just get the shit kicked. Yeah.
Yeah. Because they got to do this shit.
Yeah. Not Him. That right now. Like, man,
do you guys just sing about freedom?
See,
that's what bothers us
so much. He says, Liar.
I don't believe that this is authentic.
I don't think he,
I think he wants to be like, you guys
take shits out in the space right now.
Is that crazy horse? Yeah. Well the
first question was a normal question.
Do you guys ever feel like
it's not gravity gravity? Yeah.
It was the first question that that's
like dumb. We'd ask now. He's like,
everybody loves me. I've got to have
some. Yeah. Yeah. Where he from?
Everything's in. I'm just
boy from Oklahoma. Yeah.
Shucks. Shut up. Fuck it.
Ask ask about the shits.
That's really what I would ask
them to come all over my face.
How do you guys a jerk off?
Why y'all eat yogurt?
I want to know anytime
y'all have pornography up
there you'd have to beat off
upside down. So shut up. Where's that?
Where does the come gold was up in
space jacking my Dick Space Jack.
There's so much of this in entertainment
though in general, like the,
it's almost gotten like politics where
it's like you have to have this pristine
image to get anything going.
That's not bullshit.
That's why these podcasts are great,
right?
You can literally make it
so different too. Like,
I just did an hour and a half of press
before this on the phone radio for
upcoming dates. And it's like, you know,
you could tell when they're
cool right away. It's like,
it's like you just 30 seconds
and you're like, all right man.
And then sometimes they're like,
Ma,
you hear me married to a comedian and
what's that like? And I'm like, fuck.
And I just start like, you know,
I'm like, like one of them was like,
so are your wife coming on this joke?
I don't want to bring her with me.
He was like, ah, I'm all right. I
didn't mean to upset you. I'm like,
I'm fucking kidding. And
like it just, he was so,
they all asked the automated questions,
you know, what can people expect it?
The show? And it's just,
it's all corporate dude.
Such a world out there that I think like,
and you see happening in comedy right now.
It's like I'm starting to like,
you know, like I couldn't, ups
weren't hiring me because I was crazy,
but now it's like comedies
caught up to what I'm doing.
Comedies in a good place right now in
a great place and like these clubs are
still like, I need
clean comedy. It's like,
that doesn't exist and your world is not
real. Did you ever do juniors and Erie?
No. No, of course not.
They knew what was up.
They had a no cursing,
no innuendo,
no t bad top.
I did it twice.
I did it as a feature and a headliner and
I got one time I got off. She was like,
did you say penis when you're up there
now let me go. It's anatomically correct,
and she was like,
all right,
but just please exist in the
Mormon know ultra religious.
That's the thing is the fear is that
somebody won't buy a ticket to your dumb
show or some sponsors going to pull out,
you know,
this guy sells out multiple arena,
like 20 can we see more?
Is that
what it says next?
Just forget your differences and learning
those in yourself, or do you, is
there somewhere that has all them? No,
I put it in myself.
Oh my God.
There's only about 600 on this is 77 yeah,
there's seven years of that. Money is
never done drugs happy. It's been awhile.
Yeah.
G I do think that I'm not fussing
with wet international culture.
It's a one way or we're supportive
of each other as a team.
Worrying about what nationality,
nationality.
Just be defined on your knowledge of stuff
and then sharing that with each other.
That's a, that's a great message
for these people is a great message.
So wait,
what'd you rather give?
The guy just said that lady with
the dairy queen driving. Fucking
you want out of it to be a
large. That is, by the way,
imagine her, her telling you
what you did wrong in the order.
She would totally be your manager.
Oh, like he did so many things around.
First of all, he didn't
welcome him. Right? Didn't say
your name and the greetings.
Why didn't you ask him if he wanted
sprinkles on that? Wait, Tommy. Okay.
Would you rather have sex
with a moose soup lady?
Loose soup lady or the female astronauts?
Oh,
well I feel like Sammy doesn't know
what we're talking about and that's not
really fair. So let's um, key
him in on the Moose Soup Lady.
The uh,
there was a speedboat race and I think
West Virginia and this lady was watching,
she watched the Guy Wa wipe out
and we don't get to see her,
but she's the moose suit lady.
We imagined her and her.
We have imagination of what she's
like cause you can hear her.
Fuck you guys are doing good.
Is that Charlie Carey?
Calm down.
I come down here after I
got those stupid everything.
Alright,
you guys are doing good.
Hey,
I got you on video
dirty.
Oh God.
Don't you think that she has a
horrific sexual history from me?
She was the town bike.
There's no way.
Pretty bows dagger,
right? Tell right. Yeah.
Just 30 seconds of video.
He's a combination of like cafeteria lady
would bus drive her ride with fucking
DMV worker at somebody smokes a day.
How many packs? All of them. All of them
are helpful brand.
What do we think of Derek?
I'm thinking generics now. I think
we're rolled their own. Yeah.
Or some kind of native American ones.
We'll see.
I don't think two rolls around that
because that's just too much labor.
I think it's lazy. Gets packs. She
buys the cartons at it. Oh yeah.
If she was like CME, go get me a pack.
And you, you brought back a single pack.
She's like a pack means 20 packs.
You fucking idiot.
Like she would get on
you for only 100% yeah.
Karen,
there's no way that does not
involve a moment. Yeah. No.
And like you're like both we all three
guys on that boat or fucking if she,
if they come over from moose soup,
that is part of the equation.
Do you choose the net that
NASA astronaut take a look
at her up here on orbit.
We have kind of an international culture.
Either her or who we imagine
the moose soup lady to be.
What are you, oh definitely this
one. This will be horrible sex.
I still think she's less disgusting ass.
Not Chick all day. Why is that
Sammy? What? I mean she's,
she probably
everything together. She probably
does Ph balance on her vagina.
Like she puts a little Ph thing,
make sure that the Cidex fucking right
Bob, do you that she doesn't like
men are, that doesn't turn you off.
I've looked up the lesbians before.
I'm built like once a fuck.
Have you really hooked up with a lesbian
dude? There was this
chicken Arizona and she was,
my brother used to run strip bars and I
would always go do the gigs in Arizona.
I want to hang out with
a triple e men sometime.
I feel that you guys just have stories
more. Uh, my brother's awesome.
I would say he's a little more
conservative than I am. He's,
we're for a guy who runs a strip bar.
He's, he's a little more concise.
He's one of those libertarian dudes, you
know? So, uh, so we're kind of the same.
I'm just a little crazier. He's
more conservative and uh, you know,
so he'd run these strip bars and I'd
show up and there's this one girl was a
stripper and she was just like,
you know,
I've been a lesbian for the last like
five years or the first tick I've had
instantly you feel like Jackie Robinson,
you know,
it's like you got to represent your
people. Have you fucked this up?
They never get a shot again. Right. So I
just had to work my ass off. So yeah. Did,
I've hooked up with it. It's not,
it's, it's interesting. It's shit.
Well, wouldn't they be less
responsive to intuit at all?
She was into it. I did. I ever,
oh yeah.
I told us the last time I was having show,
but there was this like lesbian and Dana
Point, she was like a lipstick lesbian.
She was gorgeous and she
probably got cheated on by right.
Boyfriend ran to the lesbian for a little
while, you know, so it's like, yes,
sometimes they're hot.
I've done that.
I've been like on gigs were
lesbian couples come out
and you know the ones that
do and the ones to check and the chick is
fucking hot and she wants to get weird,
you know? So you're going
for the astronaut? Yes.
Over the fucking large Marge
term.
I think I'm going to go with this.
The astronauts,
I mean the moose soup lady is horrifying.
Does she? She could take out her teeth,
gum it, she'd be gumming Ya.
But the thing is with the,
with the NASA lady is
that she is a sexual,
I mean there is not a hormone,
there's not an estrogen left.
If she likes guys to begin with,
shorty,
you know, she reminds me, officer. No.
Do you guys remember the
old police academy movies?
Yeah, blond with a big rack.
He's like militant, but still love
it. She could be that. She'd be like,
she could be like a mullet. You know
what I'm saying? Business up here. Once.
Camera's off fucking party back there.
You know what I'm saying?
She might like to get weird man,
but like, she's like, I'm a woman.
I have to work harder at, you'd be
more serious. And then offstage,
she's just gobbling Russian dicks.
You know what I'm saying?
Trying to bring people together.
It would be why did you guys have
Trump and just start sucking him off.
Oh Man. Yeah. It could
be. It could be. I mean,
I still think this is a far,
far better option. Um, then calm down.
I think so. I think
that's a bad one. Mg USC.
What happens next with
Gartha? Yeah, here we go.
Native by him going to introduce
you to my better 99.9%. Um,
Michelle would actually make the trip.
I was here today,
so I want her to come to Trisha's
here. There's Trish. Hey Trish. Hi.
How are you doing?
How's that for a power couple
is fucking
power.
Couple of this is,
I feel like this nerd set it up
and then the space ladies like,
who the fuck's this bitch? Like? Yeah,
like this whole thing you set
up is all for you. Crystal.
Leah mentions he might have a girlfriend
onstage. All the girls are like,
oh, I know. She's like Garth Brooks. Oh,
here's my wife.
Oh fuck.
Oh Man. What's Trish again and
say, what's your high gas man?
I just love what you're doing for America.
Are there any bald eagles
watching you guys and listening to both
of you and just a thank you both for
your service and on growth
is probably said all that,
but just honored to be here and
uh, just I, I can't get over it.
I'm just doing the spinning
a microphone and the socks.
Do you guys have socks or ongoing?
It's just a natural. How much money
do you got to make to do that?
Like be like him dump money on you and
you're already making good money to start
bailing the bean. Like the
hat dude, he's probably,
he's probably making like a
right now with his touring,
like 80 to 100 million a year.
Would you do that for 180 million
talking like that? You're like, Oh man,
you got good cookies up
there. What? I think so.
I think so. How you got baseball,
you guys catch baseball like America.
I would love to be in that tuition.
You and the people that like listen
to this part yet. Hold me accountable.
Like you like remember when you were like
this and they show old clip of me and
I'd be like,
it was way back before cause shock.
That was before.
Yeah.
And I just go off and I just look
at someone like shut that shit off.
I honestly don't think I
could even know what to say.
Like to be normal to abnormal. Do
you know, how do you even do this?
How do you learn the
script of what's normal?
No matter how high you guys are,
you're not higher than GC.
So can you see God,
you know God's Hough Avenue Right now?
You feel like you're closer to cross.
Can you see the angels?
But you listen to like this.
Like you ever heard that song
they use in all commercials?
Like follow me.
So song that this rock band
and every fucking commercial.
But then so one thought would be,
might be good idea to play
it live at some of that.
It is the most dog shit song you'll ever,
cause it's only meant for commercial,
right?
There's like huge downtime if you weren't
exposed to certain types of music.
Like I never knew that that like
forward like a rock was a real song.
That's a,
what is that secret?
I didn't,
I thought that was just for
like a song in a commercial.
Then you hear in real life and
then you can't like it like
blow you Turkish Bob Seger.
Yeah, that's just a story. What was
the one they just had towards bi? Gene?
A Budweiser commercial.
Disgusting.
Gross. But then there are songs that
are real that I can't believe are real.
Like the other day we were in the kitchen
and a shirt on their stand up next to
you when new man here.
Toby Keith. That's real.
That's a real love.
They love it.
I like the equivalent of super
clean comics you ever meet.
They're so angry and they're bitter and
they treat people like shit cause they
made business decisions.
You know? Gorgeous.
Probably the nicest people to hang
out with. Those guys are fucking West.
Most deviant comedians are
the ones that are like,
to me the other day that Nick Dipaolo
is the nicest guy in the world. I go,
I totally make sense to me because he
goes up and says everything he wants to
say on stage. David tells like that Super
Nice. The People Tripoli's like that
are, you should fear is like
the nicest guy, you know?
But then you look at the monster
that Bill Cosby is, right?
And he's up there talking
about bullshit for years.
Nice guy. No you're not.
And then on top of that,
it's like telling all their people,
telling other people how to do comedy.
Like that was really my biggest problem
with the whole lives of slessinger thing
was that she was like, oh, you're working
dirty, blah blah blah. Low hanging fruits.
Like you're not doing rocket
science up there. You know,
and I'd love you to death.
But it's like,
I'm just tired of like people who make
business decision getting mad at people
who go up there and just try to give
a piece of their soul for their art.
You know, I, you know, being
the Carl Sagan of Dick Jokes,
which I've often called myself,
um,
I just like to go up there and just
fucking have fun and like, you know,
financially it's, it's led itself to
where it is, you know? And I just like,
do you want, don't worry about what
I, if you want to be a businessperson,
go do it. Just don't tell other people
how they should be doing comedy.
That's my whole problem. Don't, don't tell
everyone else. Right. Yeah. It's like,
you want to be a rapist who
does clean comedy. Yay for
you, Bill Cosby. Yeah. Right.
Wow. Isn't that nuts? That's
funny. He gave so much,
so many unsolicited lessons to
people caused me like how to live,
how to dress, how to fucking remember that
Wanda Sykes moment where it's like, oh,
she's like, how'd you guys do back in your
days? And he's like, we spoke English.
And I'm like, everyone's like, oh
yeah. At that, at the award show.
And then you find out he's probably
roofing everybody there. Oh man,
there's a sterling sharp guy and
not stir something Deron sharp.
He was sharper. He was a football player.
Don't give that to sterling Sharpe.
Jesus Christ. Oh, he's great. Yeah. The
one guy who went to jail for like forever,
he was like a hall of Famer.
Good looking black athlete sharp is shit.
Yeah.
And you would be roofing girls so crazy.
He could just stack change
prison for a long time.
Now it's fucking terrible.
It was really crazy man that he um,
but that dude, he was in the league for
a long time. He was like all decade.
And then like all the charges
were like in, uh, the,
the division town teams
that you'd be like, oh,
like he had like four in New Orleans
and check the schedule and then the next
day how many calls with Ecog,
whatever piece of shit.
That guy who said this years ago,
they were like,
the best serial killer would be
as a traveling comic. I mean,
there was the guy who was a rapist,
the famous comic who would like ever,
he'd go play campuses and there was
rapes on every campus where he performed,
looked up his beard.
Right.
His fucking signature still on the
wall at the comedy Magic Club. Yeah.
It's up because everyone's signed
things for years and they're like,
that dude's in prison. Darrin sharper
was on the hall. Fame ballot. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Well, I mean we
remembered after Oj got accused,
it took like NBC like a month to fire him.
The fuck go crazy.
Let's hold off for a little bit.
Vince champ. That's his name.
The comedian was raping people.
Is there any comedy of him on Youtube?
I bet you hear a clean comic.
He was the,
he wants star search in 1900.
Yeah. Proves our theory. Yeah.
The biggest psychos are the ones
who are pretending not to be,
who were just talking about things.
Everything.
Like I don't think you have to
work dirty to be funny. Am I right?
Oh my God. What's up
a Walmart? Am I right?
Am I got cats and dogs are different.
They are totally different
there. Is that, what's his
name has been on here before?
Brido Bryden Stein and he told that great
story about Norm Mcdonald and Iowa 20
years ago where he went, um, and it was,
it was built as a family friendly show
and it was like three or 4,000 people and
they bought and I'm
Darrell Hammond went up,
then Jim brewer and then norm and norms.
First joke was about,
he saw a video of a pig fucking
woman.
Brido is at the show.
He says as he's saying
it like you just like
stand up.
And then norm was like,
what did you want to talk about
losing your luggage at the airport?
I'm with you dude.
Of course.
For that they like this.
I wish I do.
There's part of me that wishes I could
like that stuff. Oh, in the room.
And then I could just watch friends,
marathons and think they're fantastic.
I want to love network television.
Let me love this one of those couples,
they're going around the world.
That's crazy. And I just
like, I go home, I like,
my mother is like this,
she's like convince Islamic rapist.
Jihadis are everywhere in upstate New
York. We live by cows. By the way,
there's a cow crossing a block from where
I live that the conspiracy theory guy
can't believe his mom has a conspiracy
theory about the most watched too much
CNN, right? Yeah. Too much of
that shit. So I like, she like,
she wanted to come see me in Syracuse,
has playing the funny bone and she
wanted to stay in my hotel room.
Like I'm the only guy
that brings back chicks.
That's your mom after your fucking show.
But she comes and she slept with her
purse in the bed next to her like this.
And I'm like, mom, the only person
could steal that is me. That,
what are you trying to
say about me? But she, uh,
all she watches his HGN and
it's just every shows a,
a gay guy selling real estate in fucking
Manhattan. But she's pleased, right?
She's had, she's contagious.
Loves it. Yeah. She just loves it.
But every show's a gay guy selling
fucking real estate. Go ahead.
The one show that I don't understand
why anybody can watch are those like the
Kelly and Regis in the morning that that
Kelly rip on whoever now it's Ryan
Seacrest or they talk about nothing for an
hour.
Like who's who's tuning in?
What Weird Shit do you think Ryan
Seacrest is into? He's got a,
he's big on that like Garth
persona, so he's like, hey guys,
it's like all smiles and we got the
special kids from the Olympics here, Matt,
and they really let us know we can
do anything. We dream about it.
We'll be right back with special kits.
And then he turns and what do you think
that the thing that he says that next is
get this fucking Juda stop looking at
him like he says he doesn't like to get
pegged in the ass.
There's no way he gets whatever weird
chick he's doing a reality show with.
Put a big fucking angry red
deldot and just no lube.
Just Ram it. Don't tell him. Heard
him make him cry and that's how,
who gets on the show? For sure. Being
the weird shit. Allegedly. Yeah.
So many of them do, especially with
these, these phony personas. Man,
you know it was not funny at all.
The fucking president,
and he actually gave me a shout out.
I wanted to show you guys,
it's pretty nuts.
Saw this video.
Thank you very much Mr. Trump for,
for mentioning me.
Don't want a champion. Yes, it
was a champion. He still needs to.
What a champion and I'm still running
this motherfucker. You heard it right?
Still one in the motherfucker. Look
sloppy. You heard it right? Look,
slumps, deer run running the
motherfucking Anniston. Bert,
you can't be a water champion.
You're too fat.
Oh Wow. Damn articulate man, president,
president. Oh my God. That
guy's eloquent when those to say
we been ran. You out the industry.
I don't know what you're doing.
And it looks like when it comes to not
hold it. Stay out of my motherfucking.
Yeah, you heard it right.
Stay out my mother fucking go.
I let the secret service one wild on you
rather than, you know what's the most
pres presidential thing? Bomb
is this gold grills. That's 11.
Heres the fucking best.
And his wig it,
his skin is so clean. Yes.
Unbelievable. And he's been,
he's keeping his promises.
He's building
just white.
The wow.
Is it mother fucking time taking it all
over the world because that's why I'm
taking it all over the world on my tour
from the hood to the White House you had
right. My tour from the hook to
the White House La. Get ready.
Oh Shit.
Wait for the prompt for Trump to come
out with these little Trump nineties bed.
That's what I meant. Trump little
Trump. Nice. It's Lil lil Trump,
little Trump nineties on Instagram.
This is precedent as my president and um,
you know,
check them out by president. This guy's
definitely my president and my president.
Sure. Man. Much better than
the old cousin. There's a
real question right here.
He'll get shit done.
He's getting it done.
Let me get that pm from a
Germany pregnant, right? Yeah.
I mean that guy would
totally hit Merkel's. That
her name Marie. Yeah, right.
He totally lost dog shit. Totally raw
dog. You'd get a fucking trade back.
Go it. Get your pregnant now. You got
to work with me. You'll have my baby
Merkel who would definitely drop a seed
and Merkel and be like so different.
It's such an old picture.
We've got to update this picture.
We took that at Sears years ago.
Great.
It's so great. They looked at us
like, what the fuck are you guys?
You're that one brother in that family
of the parents who had 90 kids and,
but you're the one that
molested all of them.
You figure blasted all
your sister. Oh Man. Jeez.
Okay. Too Much Jesus Cruz.
Now. It's never a man.
Um, wait, so that people know. You
mentioned there's an album out.
Is there an album out?
I have a double album out.
It's called the diabolical.
The first album is a storytelling.
I got some great stories about how I got
away from a police helicopter chase a
couple of gigs. I did it in the desert,
some crazy shit, special Olympics show.
And then the second album was called
Friday night late show and it's basically
me bombing for an hour.
I so admire the guys that do shit like
that though. I'm putting it out there.
Where did you record that
Sacramento punchline? And
they were just sloppy, sloppy.
And I'm like, you know what, how many
times you be able to put a double album?
I'm like, fuck it. I'm going to put
it out and see how it goes. And uh,
about five minutes and I realized this
crowd is not playing along and then just
start ripping them a new asshole for
like 45 minutes. And I had the best time.
Really? Yeah. So I put it out.
So it's like two hours of power
and there's like, there's, is
there a major bombing moments?
Oh yeah.
But even my bombing is entertaining.
I go out in a blaze of glory. You
know what? I'm going for it. Oh yeah.
I'm going to leave a mark. I'll grab
the fucking planes, fucking controllers,
flight rate into the building. I don't
give a fuck. You know what I'm saying?
I like to have fun. I mean, that's
just, Oh, our late night comedy.
You got to get blood from a stone
sometimes of that comedy show.
I mean, on what, like explain to
people what late night. Oh our means,
even though they know,
okay, the best way to describe it, you
are the hundredth man at a 99 gang bang.
It is.
It is sloppy beat up,
ready to go home and you got to
somehow get a reaction from this crowd.
Everything's been talked
about a thousand times.
They've seen every famous person they've
ever wanted to see and you just got to
somehow get them to not
only laugh but you can't.
You've got to entertainment enough
that they stay for the next guy.
So there's all this kind of pressure
on you to do it. So I love it. Yeah.
On those late night spots to people
ever like, do you see guys go like if
this sucks, they're just like,
just sabotage the spot and be like,
well fuck it and like not try.
Does that happen?
I think occasionally that happens,
but I think like all the people at
the end are kind of like friends with
everybody and we kind of all got her like,
we,
I keep these people here for the
next person. Do you really do?
I think everybody kind of works together
in this weird way and I have energy at
that hour. Right. And it's,
it's the comedy store. I mean,
regardless of whether you're
doing a, uh, uh, you know, uh,
nine 45 or a 1:00 AM,
it's still the comedy store and
no matter how how late you are,
you've still blessed. I have to
be like one of what, 3000, 4,000,
5,000 comics in La to get a
spot in that room and that time.
So it's had like 40 people working
that night, basically like,
you know what I mean? Like crazy.
Like this, this size, it's good.
Attrition rate is so crazy for comedy.
Like when we all started
around the same time,
when you think about who we started with,
it's crazier.
It's harder than Harvard law. Like
it's so hard. There's nobody left.
It's basically comedy store versus
New York City comedy. Like that's all.
If there was no comedy store,
I think La comedy be in Breely bad shape,
but it's the one place, it's
kind of Mecca. Whereas you
go out to like New York,
it's like such a different fun vibe out
there and you can explore by think the
comedy store is the one place where
you can take, well, I don't know.
The lineups are so killer now,
but it's like it's Mecca.
So it's like even if you're doing
a one o'clock in the morning spot,
you still want to do the
best that you can. Yeah.
Because if you start tanking it,
they'll take that away from you and
they'll put somebody else in there who,
they will watch it
though. Okay. Keep an eye,
keep tabs on and we'll get out if like,
you know,
like this guy's just Sam snitches to man.
There's some snitches
crybaby bullshit going on,
which I've wouldn't ruled and never
talk bad about a comic tool booker.
I think that's just the worst fucking
figure. The world. That's real shit.
I think that's the low, I mean like
it's just below stealing jokes.
He goes stealing jokes and then shit
talking. Even if I don't like somebody,
I would never talk shit to them
to a booker. But people do that.
And so you get those late night spots.
I think they're the only,
they're the only spots and work on
shit store. Those early spots, man,
you got to fucking sling heat
because it's just murder's row.
When you get like past 1130,
it's like it starts to thin out,
you can take a couple more chances.
And that's kind of what I do miss that
part of the comedy store where it was
like a workout room. But I
also understand that, you know,
Adam and Eric and all those guys have
to have that place sold out or else
they'll knock it down and turn it into
like a fucking condominium or some shit
like that. And by the way, that
uh, as far as workout rooms,
I feel like there's really
nothing like the belly room.
That belly room is like fucking amazing.
I'm starting a new new room.
It's called the Dojo and a,
I'm going to doing it.
We're doing it Thursdays and the
goal is to kind of get it going.
So it's like you can actually go
work on shit. That'd be great.
It's right down the street from the comedy
store. The show would start at eight.
You guys could do your spots and
then run down to your store set and,
but you can do 1520 of
just working on shit.
See, I like when it's,
I like when the show,
like people say work on
shit at all kinds of shows,
but I like when it's designated as such,
like when it's advertised as such.
So the audience goes,
this is an actual gym right now that
changes the dynamic of the show.
You really feel like you
can take real chances.
It's not like you're doing a regular
Saturday night show somewhere and they're
like, work shit out. And
you're like, okay. But it's
like when the show was like,
that's why I liked that, that stand
up on this spot. And I love that show.
And uh, use of new materials show. It's
like, this is, this is not proven stuff.
This is,
you know what I mean?
You really feel like you can
really jump into half the
be able to fail.
Yeah.
And sometimes in la it's very hard.
Like the Improv is like Pablo Francisco
long time ago told me never work on new
shit. The improv, like that's the office,
that's where the industry goes. Hangouts.
Now the comedy store is kind of that,
but it's like,
and then he used to be at the comedy store
cause there was like 20 people in the
crowd and everybody's doing coke in
the back and fuck and having weird fuck
weirdness. You could work on shit. But
it's not like that anymore. So I uh,
I'm working on this place every night.
You sit fucking 50 people in there.
It's packed out. It's a great
idea. Let us know when you,
when it's up and running Russia,
my goal is to get gone Wednesday
through Saturday and have this guy,
my buddy TK him and I run it.
And then you could show up every day
and whenever you want to work on shit.
Oh wait, is it t? K? Um, what's
his name? I forget tks last name,
but he's like a calm around
forever. Yeah. But he, yeah,
he's a friend of mine and I cause it set
this bar that I saw on like the use of
an upstairs. I'm like disappeared.
Great Place for Comedy Club.
And I go there and Teekay's run room.
We'd been friends for a long time.
Like I want to do a new room here, so
a new night. He's like, let's do it.
So we've done it.
It's been packed out the last two times.
I want to start getting every week
I want to get it so starts running.
That's cool.
By the way,
I think it's so funny that they had like
the old cheat code to getting past for
Mitzi was. I love that. That it was
like ethnic thing, family thing,
your favorite bit. I wish I had known
that I fucking did not get passed for her.
And I remember I was on
stage and I look and she was,
you know, straight back like we're
Adam basically sits and um, I,
I could in the middle of like first bit
or like second bit and I can see her
talking to somebody and I'm like, ah,
getting hijacked. And like, yeah. Yeah.
And I'm just like trying to like say
what I'm saying and then, uh, you know,
I'm turning here and I
would look back and she was,
I could see her still being like, no, no,
no, like just, just having a conversation.
I was like, fuck. And then I, you know,
I'm like, what happened? They're like, no,
I should know. Ah, man.
But a comic the same night,
I remember this opened with like,
I know what you're thinking.
Like I look like this past,
yeah, well she was old school, you
know, and she's little, but she,
she had a vision to,
there's all these famous stories
of like famous people coming up,
calling her up going, hey, I'm blah
blah blah mom, blah blah, blah.
I'd love to play your club.
And she's like, I'm gonna
fuck, hang up. You know? So I,
I, I get, she treated me well.
I don't know what it was.
I was getting tons of spots in
there and it, I, it was a blessing.
It was also kinda
encouraged cause you'd like,
you're getting like five spots
a week at the comedy store.
I don't want to go on the road.
I'm make money here.
I'm doing all these live
shows, selling all the sad
stuff, you know, I mean it's a,
I'm making all these a sponsorship money
so I don't want to go on the road as
much as I did it and then it's like
becomes this kind of false victory.
So I think the key is to
do a little bit there,
then go out and practice
your Kung Fu out there.
It's like now you're getting a
lot of spots there and it's like,
it's such an interesting thing.
And the reason I think it's one of the
hardest rooms to do is because there's no
host you have to go up.
It can be like five o'clock fire,
like Rogan just flame
throwed that fucking room.
And guess who has to go up right after
that. You're right. And you know,
it's so interesting,
isn't it?
To up your game.
You gotta you know you can't really
fuck around and makes you focus on what
you're,
I think I'm going to ask the file Joey
Dsl the time just to see if I could crack
that code. Cause it's just, I mean
it's a combination of like funny,
well-written, super energy. I,
I followed him couple times
for the first five minutes.
I'm like Charlie Brown's mom,
no one's listened.
I'm like Mall Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah
Wah Wah Wah and everything show it is,
it's uncle Joe.
And then after they settled,
either way,
that dude,
especially for 15 to 20
minutes is a nightmare.
Like you know, it's like that
amount of time for him is like,
cause he can really like just
drop a grenade, you know,
it doesn't have to like it's,
it's
Rogan used to bring me out with
them and I'd always have to,
I'd have to fall Diaz. Yeah. Yeah.
And one time in San Jose Dude,
he opened up and did like 12 minutes
of like next level as seating material,
like next level.
And I just want to go,
what do I have that can
fall back and it's nothing.
It's nothing and you go rogue. You're,
why are you making me follow this guy?
I go following Joey Diaz at the Joe Rogan
show is like featuring or middling for
van Halen,
but the opening act is David Lee Roth.
Yeah,
I had it.
I had a number of Rogan tour dates where
I would follow him too and I'd be like,
this sucks man. I used to be, you
know what I do just settle in harder.
The material,
not tried to fight what he had done.
Just try to like stay in the in the
material and see if like maybe a minute
later they'll kind of gravitate to you.
That's kind of what I've learned man over
like at some point at the comedy store,
my material was carrying me
when I was like had Bambi legs,
you know where I'm like, Oh yeah,
just let the material carry me.
Right now it's kind of like I
can fall anybody. I've been fine.
I mean like horse during my first two
years at the comedy store for at least the
first year I got bumped by dice
every night. He just come in,
he would come and find me on the
lineup and be like, I want to go here.
And he would just do an hour before me
and then rogue and I had the fall Rogan
all the time.
So any week I was either following Rogan
dice or Eddie Griffin doing literally
two and a half,
three hours.
I just remember, I remember seeing
him do, um, by the way, way,
but you know a work there
just hanging out there.
And he was like standing on
room on tables in the Oh,
are like walking from table to table
smoking and talking about a Jewish
conspiracy theories about how
the highways or the roads in DC,
how they design them. And I was like, what
is going? And I wasn't a regular there,
so I was just like stepping in. I'm like,
this is what happens here. Have this guy,
he's talks about these crazy theories and,
and smokes and nobody says anything
like it was bananas to watch, you know,
like it, I was really, I was so floored
by what I saw and not in a good way.
I was just like, I need to stay
away from this place. They get nuts.
Well,
I was born and bred in that shit and
then I will go on the road and thinking
everything's the comedy store and just
go nuts. And it was just like, Eh,
it was like wrong thing.
So I had to readjust myself.
It's interesting to go out going,
okay, not everything's a comedy source.
So my style of comedy, I call a gator
roll. It's where it's like, you know,
alligators kill things.
They,
they grab it at the top and then they
slowly drag it down and then they drowned
in spin around. I started really simple
with maybe some shit, my pants material,
right. Bring them in. Yeah. Relatability.
And then next thing you know,
I'm doing a bit about smoking crack
with his fucking black robot guy.
That happened to me one
time. There you go. Perfect.
Oh good dude. Gimme gimme the plugs.
Where can people find everything?
Uh, you guys check out my double
album. The diabolical, it's on iTunes.
It's two hours of superpower. That
Sam Tripoli's album. It's great.
I'm going to shoot a special,
I'm going to shoot my own special
and I'm just going to put it out.
I'm not even gonna try to
sell it anywhere. Where you
going to shoot it? You know,
I'm trying to find the right place.
I want to do the viper room
cause I just love doing standup.
They're perfect for you and it's got
kind of like a name cache and it's just
really small and simple. I just
want to shoot a name, your price.
I'm going to probably shoot
that in the next month or two.
You gonna wear your Mister
Magoo glasses or no?
I don't know man. I don't
know. Hip Hop rap video.
I might have corn rows by then and
then check out my podcast. Tinfoil hat.
I just did a swap cast with a Duncan
Trussell and now you just did woman Doug
Stanhope just go to Tin
Tinfoil hat with Sam Tripoli.
And a check on my youtube page.
I upload something every day.
youtube.com backslash Sam Tripoli.
I'll put something I call
opiate for the acids,
which is just a 30 minutes of
just Crowdwork me ripping people.
And then I do something called twerking
in politics where I take twerk videos
from, uh, uh,
Instagram and I put political messages
over them and I tried to spell you're a
madman. I love your Instagram and wait,
do you still do punchdrunk right? Yeah,
I do punch drunk with Ari. Shaffir I
want to show you guys the bleaching,
but we're out of time. But, uh, I did it
with Ari Shaffir and Jason Tebow and uh,
you know, we're about to
launch our own network. We,
I'm talking to you a year ago,
but the fucking websites finally done
good. And we're going to just get a,
an all sports comedy channel going.
I'm happy for you.
I love you.
You're the first,
you're the power couple of comedy.
You're by far the funniest
and the fact that you guys,
you guys are huge in the [inaudible].
You guys should be on
everything all the time.
But I think you guys have your
own wonderful things going on.
You don't fucking need that. You're
the fucking two funniest people I know.
And you're the nice people. I know.
We love you. Thanks for coming.
Did I hijack your show? No. Okay. Not at
all. It got weird with the pedophilia.
We weirded him.
This thing about marrying your mom
stuff like it's a very common theme.
Yeah, no, no, it's all, it's all good man.
It gets weird enough here.
I jerked out to a cousin wants to go.
It's um, it's fine cause these to
marry cousins and royal family,
just like the gays, just
like the gays case. So, um,
you guys please check
out all of Sam's stuff.
Thank you again for listening to the show.
And we'll leave you with in Toronto
at the end of the month. Oh,
see on the ballot of
top dogs balls by skid.
Thank you always for sending
in the music and I'm,
we'll leave you with that and
we'll see you next week. Bye guys.
I'm seeing my dad's balls.
I've seen my dad's balls.
I've seen my dad
balls.
His balls were enormous.
Yeah.
I'm seeing my dad's balls.
I'm seeing my dad's boss.
These balls.
Enormous.
Gigantic.
Okay,
awesome.
You can
look like animal
testicles,
animal testicles.
That sounds awful.